ladies and gentlemen I am Conan O'Brien
or or as I'm known in Harlem the albino
rhino this man pinched my nipple right
there by the way I was looking for a
soft touch and I got a pinch you're a
pervert all right there you go she
doesn't pick
[Applause]
yeah now I'm using that at the trial I
have to say I love it here in Harlem
what a great week we're having so far
it's such an amazing neighborhood my
favorite thing my favorite thing about
Harlem is you can buy absolutely
anything from the street vendors here
anything yeah yeah that's why after the
show tonight you're all invited back to
my hotel to watch a bootleg copy of
Bride of Chucky you come along I love a
wedding yeah you do yeah now of course I
left I left New York City eight years
ago we left eight years ago yeah and
since then
thank you that went just as we rehearsed
it remember to all when I tell you I
love ya all right we didn't know you're
gone Oh since then there have been so
many changes to this city since we left
I was walking around today and I noticed
that these Starbucks near my old
apartment has been replaced by a totally
different Starbucks blew my mind Wow big
change for Twitter yesterday now if you
heard about this Twitter has officially
doubled the maximum length of a tweet to
280 characters double yeah in a related
story president Trump's thumbs have been
rushed to intensive care
[Applause]
speaking of Trump it has come out that
President Trump once wanted to have a
rally right here at the Apollo Theater
but he was told no technically
technically he was told oh hell no
Wow
yeah
[Applause]
you